♪ ♪
>> Greg: OUT OF DUMB STORIES
COMES A GREAT LESSON.
STARTS WITH A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT POSTING PHOTOS AND HER
PROM DRESS ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
SHE IS WHITE AND WORE A
TRADITIONAL CHINESE DRESS.
THIS ACCORDING TO THE MEDIA
SPARKED OUTRAGE OVER CULTURAL
APPROPRIATION.
FIRST, ALWAYS BE AWARE OF SUCH
B.S.
STORIES BASED ON FAKING OFFENSE.
THE MEDIA BREATHLESSLY COVERS IT
BECAUSE WE ARE SUCKERS FOR
OUTRAGE.
THE CULTURAL APPROPRIATION
OFFENSE IS A SHAM APPEAR THE
IDEA THAT IT'S RACIST TO
INCORPORATE SOMETHING FROM
ANOTHER CULTURE IS SO MORALLY
BANKRUPT IT'S ACTUALLY DEADLY.
OVER TIME, HEALTHY PEOPLE ADOPT
PRACTICES THAT ENHANCE THEIR
LIVES.
MEANING THEY STEAL GOOD THINGS
COMING OUT THE BAD.
ALL THINGS COME FROM SOMEWHERE
ELSE.
APPROPRIATION ISN'T JUST A
COMPLEMENT TO A CULTURE.
IT'S HOW CIVILIZATIONS THRIVE.
DO YOU WEAR PAJAMAS?
IF YOU ARE NOT AN INDIAN MUSLIM,
YOU ARE RACIST.
PAJAMAS ORIGINATED FROM INDIAN
MUSLIMS.
GOD FORBID THE SHEETS YOU SLEEP
ON OUR OF EGYPTIAN COTTON.
DO YOU EAT YOGURT?
HOW RACIST IS THAT ARE
APPROPRIATE THE DIET OF CENTRAL
ASIAN HERDSMEN FROM 6,000 BC?
DO YOU WALK UPRIGHT?
HOW DARE YOU STEAL THE PRACTICE
INITIATED BY THE EARLIEST
HOMINID FROM ETHIOPIA?
IF YOU LIVE YOUR LIFE BY
AVOIDING CULTURAL APPROPRIATION,
YOU WOULD HAVE NO LIFE
WHATSOEVER.
YOU DIDN'T EVEN EVOLVE.
AT BEST, YOU WOULD JUST BE
STUPID.
WHICH IS A TRAIT FOUND IN ALL
CULTURES AND STORIES GENERATED
BY TWITTER.
YOU KNOW, IT ALL STARTED WITH
SOME KID NAMED JEREMY.
HE SAID MY CULTURE IS NOT YOUR
GD PROM DRESS.
HE GOT 43,000 RETWEETS SO THAT
MAKES IT STORY.
>> Dana: PART OF IT IS WE ARE
SO, WE HAVE BECOME SO DEPENDENT
ON TWITTER TO HELP US FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE NEWS IS AND COVER
STUPID STUFF LIKE THIS.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
>> Dana: THIS POOR GIRL.
SHE JUST SAID I THOUGHT IT WAS A
BEAUTIFUL DRESS.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A BEAUTIFUL
DRESS.
SHE FOUNDED AT A VINTAGE SHOP IN
UTAH.
JESSE, CULTURAL APPROPRIATION.
IMAGINE IF A MIRACLE DRUG IS
MADE IN GERMANY, IF YOU ARE NOT
FROM GERMANY, I CAN'T TAKE THAT
DRUG.
APPROPRIATING THEIR MEDICINAL
ASK FOR TEES.
>> Jesse: LIKE IF I WANTED TO
WEAR LEDERHOSEN AND GO TO
OKTOBERFEST.
I AS AN AMERICAN CAN'T DO THAT?
>> Kimberly: PERFECT OUTFIT
FOR YOU.
>> Jesse: IT'S CRAZY.
IT MEANS THE CRUSTY HIPPIE WHITE
GIRLS THAT ARE LIBERALS CAN'T DO
THE DREADLOCKS WITH THE RASTA
THING.
THAT MEANS BLACK AMERICANS CAN'T
WEAR ENGLISH P COATS.
THERE'S A WHOLE LIST OF THINGS
YOU CAN OR CANNOT DO IF YOU'RE
GOING TO BUY BY THE RULES OF
CULTURAL PREPARATION.
>> Jesse: REMEMBER WHEN YOU
HAD TO WEAR THE JACKET AND
SHORTS?
>> Jesse: BAD FASHION
APPROPRIATION.
>> Greg: JUAN, IS THERE ANY
EXAMPLE OF CULTURAL
APPROPRIATION THAT IS ACTUALLY
REAL?
AND OUTRAGE?
I CAN UNDERSTAND INDIVIDUAL
MISTAKES AT HALLOWEEN, SOMETHING
THAT'S VERY STUPID.
CULTURAL APPROPRIATION MEANING
LIKE, I AM WEARING A PEACOAT.
IT'S BRITISH.
I SHOULDN'T BE WEARING THAT.
>> Juan: ONE THAT OUTRAGED ME.
YOU LOVE KANYE WEST.
OKAY, IF YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE --
>> Jesse: ENIMEN TOOK THAT
ALONG TIME AGO.
>> Dana: WAIT UNTIL KANYE
SINGS A COUNTRY SONG.
>> Greg: THE FIRST RAPPER WAS
REALLY DAVID BOWIE.
>> Juan: HE MARRIED A BLACK
WOMAN.
SEE WHAT I AM TALKING ABOUT?
I WAS INTERESTED IN THIS BECAUSE
OF THE IDEA THAT AS KIMBERLY WAS
SAYING A MOMENT AGO, YOU LOOK
BACK AT THE HOLLOWING THING AND
YOU GET A LOT OF THE
FRATERNITIES AND SORORITIES THEY
GET IN TROUBLE AND THEY SAID
THEY ARE DRESSING UP, LET'S SAY,
LIKE BLACK PEOPLE OR THEY PUT ON
A SOMBRERO, ACTUALLY MAY 5 IS
COMING UP.
LIKE SPANISH PEOPLE.
HOLD ON, WHAT ARE YOU DOING
HERE?
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF MAKING FUN
OF US IF YOU ARE PART OF US AND
UNDERSTAND IT.
I DON'T THINK THIS YOUNG LADY
WAS MAKING FUN OF CHINESE
PEOPLE.
I THINK SHE THOUGHT IT WAS A
NICE DRESS.
>> Greg: IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
DRESS.
>> Juan: I THINK IT IS
OVERDONE.
>> Kimberly: YOU LOOK IN THE
FASHION MARKET, SHANGHAI, REALLY
PRETTY DRESSES CELEBRATING THE
FASHION THE TAPESTRY, MATERIALS
THAT ARE USED TO MAKE DRESSES.
I HAVE A VERY NICE BLACK DRESS
KIND OF LIKE THAT.
IT'S SILKEN HAS A LITTLE BIT OF
A PATTERN.
SHE WANTED TO CHOOSE IT BECAUSE
SHE THOUGHT IT WAS A BEAUTIFUL
DRESS AND SHE WANTED TO HAVE A
SPECIAL NIGHT AND LOOK GREAT.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S HARD BECAUSE PEOPLE IMPUGN
MOTIVES PERHAPS.
>> Dana: SEEMS LIKE THIS
GENERATION OF HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS, THE WOMEN, YOUNG GIRLS
ARE PICKING DRESSES.
THEY DON'T ALL LOOK THE SAME.
PART OF THE THING IS TO SHOW
MORE PERSONALITY.
>> Kimberly: INDIVIDUALITY.
>> Greg: NOT JUST WOMEN.
MEN ARE PICKING DRESSES AS WELL.
>> Juan: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THE PRAYER GESTURE?
WAS THAT A LITTLE BIT MUCH?
>> Dana: NOEL.
IT'S FINE.
>> Jesse: PRAYING IS OKAY.
>> Greg: THE VILLAIN IS THE
PERSON TWEETED.
HE KNEW, THE OUTRAGE, HE WASN'T
EVEN MAD.
HE KNEW IT WOULD GET PICKED UP